it is going to significantly
affect these defendants rights to a fair
and impartial trial it took Superior
Judge Scott McAfee less than two hours
to come to a decision he rejected the
arguments of trump-aligned lawyers
Kenneth chesborough and Sydney Powell
that they should be tried singly and
separately in this racketeering case I'm
not finding the severance from Mr chesbo
or Powell is necessary to achieve a fair
determination of the guilt or innocence
for either defendant in this case
prosecutors want all defendants tried
together in late October they told the
judge that the trial would take the same
amount of time whether it was for 2 or
19 defendants and the judge has asked
them to appear on Tuesday next week to
present further argument to support
their case studs we contend that we must
prove the entire conspiracy against each
and every one charged
each and every one charged so the court
in the interest of judicial economy
would have to make the decision as to
whether or not the court wants to try
the same case 19 times
the prosecution says it expects the
trial to take four months after jury
selection and that more than 150
witnesses will be called jury selection
can take a long time for example jury
selection is still underway in a
racketeering case that began in this
court in January and we need we plan to
make that October 23rd trial date stick
the question to be resolved whether the
trial of all 19 defendants begins on
October the 23rd given the timelines a
trial that begins on this date but will
conclude around the 4th of March next
year that's the date set for the
beginning of the federal trial against
the former president whose diary during
a presidential campaign is getting more
and more crowded judge McAfee is likely
to take a final decision on this trial
date after he hears from prosecutors
next Tuesday
Atlanta Atlanta
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera